[Music]
which is very meta isn't it because it
itself is a a multi-syllabic word i love
that word with multi-cell maybe many
many syllables many individual building
blocks of words no one liked it but i
like it
[Music]
yeah yeah um there's probably about
um 80 people in here handsome if you
have an audi it should be eight people
one two three there's more than that
you're just not admitting it right
you do know that an auntie belly button
is actually just a hernia that's what it
is it's just an earlier
it's fun though because now when all
those old blokes are like sorry i've got
you like me too
oh really really
i'm
retroactively reinstating the animals
just because i do a bunch of these for
kids sometimes and they always say
unicorn i have to go wow what an amazing
suggestion aren't you clever jessica
well done
and inside i'm like i [ __ ] hate you
it's so tedious but um we can take it
but i want you to give me um a
a movie a classic movie
because there's like there's a movie
called the cube in this movie called
cube and they're different so like
labyrinth the david bowie one with all
the puppets okay um
that doesn't really make it a better
suggestion
so
can we can we have another suggestion
for a movie i'll still put that in if i
remember
animal out of this oh hypothetical land
what
shitless okay
[Applause]
are you recording schindler's list i'm
sorry if you are a child of the back who
suggested that i just want to make it
fun fun fact about schindler's list um
steven spielberg made it in 1993 the
same year that he made jurassic park
and he asked the studio for this isn't
funny by the way asked to do money to
make schindler's list after originally
thinking he'd let another director make
it so he didn't think he was up to the
task of making it and they went we'll
give you all the money you want but you
have to make jurassic park first and he
was like why they were like we think
that after you've made a very sad movie
about the holocaust do you want to make
a bug movie about dinosaurs so that's
that's why am i in order
that's all um would you sit at home and
clap wikipedia
[Laughter]
belly button
still have it and a unicorn in
schindler's list let's come to this side
of the room like a rapper oh there's two
hands oh no you just just scratched your
eye with those personalities yeah thank
you from there
take your winkie um
do you know
do you know dave who is actually taking
away from the child's office no no he's
a comedian he performs on the stand up
so he just tells stories of how much
[ __ ] went on in the filming election
i can't remember his surname which is
disappointing because we keep together
quite a bit and every time we just like
come on tell me another filthy story
when i say it was like the acts not not
the rabbits obviously they [ __ ] all the
time uh
and it wasn't the baby in the sun either
that wasn't
essentially just yeah cool thinking from
the teletubbies don't even say in the
teletubbies i feel like you didn't need
that
kinky winky i know was a character in
you blyton's far away tree maybe
was that true
okay
was there another
[Music]
i was just at a show and we wrapped
about the same old rat admittedly it was
a really good part of the wreck as well
but you can't say the same suggestion
twice
disabled
and
i am reinstating the no animal ban now
find a disabled raccoon what's wrong
with this raccoon
[Laughter]
so let's just go to these multi-syllabic
unicorn in schindler's list belly button
we've got the uh the disabled raccoon
who's short-sighted and and how did i
forget the other one it was the fourth
one
kinky winky of course okay
um
i'm sorry the people who were just at
that show i
usually i use this beat but um the b i
use that that shine i'm going to use
today i was just warming up on it
because i was feeling more live so you
get the same feet but uh a different
wrap so i don't think you wouldn't even
[ __ ] notice anyway right this is
i don't even [ __ ] know is this a
freestyle about all that [ __ ] is it
gonna be good most [ __ ] definitely
let's do it
kings of the second show too soon
[Music]
but this judge is the distance how to
blurry when he approaches his life is
this some food yeah i really hope it oh
no that was just a rock when it comes to
raccoon rummaging he has to stop going
to a food bank getting
[Music]
why because i am a jew they cut the
little tip of my horn right off and so
i'm over here there's no trough for me
to eat on it's very nasty i apologize
that all of the evil nazis wrote you in
here aren't you annoying for a while i'm
inside i can still bring some joy who's
that there ramul finds or is it
josephine's he'll have a [ __ ] good
time he'll be walking in with his nazi
hat he's like what is a jewel basically
a rat that's a genuine line from the
film not opinion why are you feeling
really weird it's a silly one ah i wish
he didn't rap about something so tragic
switch it up like multi-syllabic
much better than one solo kind of ironic
though that's so low
[Music]
itself is so clever it's got so many
syllables we're feeling very meta but
it's even less funny than the jewish war
so
[Music]
shining reflecting from my belly ring
i'm walking
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like a coat hanger and did see with the
green straight line and then lala she'd
be looking fine walking over with the
tiny little twirl tikki and did you a
male she was a girl and then who's that
[Music]
[Music]
cleaner
[Music]